it's a nice hearty line dance so you all
kind of stand next to each other
[Laughter]
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast i am your host
your roast coming queen once caught
shoplifting at the fair oaks mall bath
and body works elise morales
and with us today we
have just one of my favorite people
she's an actress and comedian
a star of screens large and small
graduate of lasalle academy please
welcome alyssa limperis
oh my god it's so nice to have a credit
include my lasalle academy alma mater
it's very grounding it's very comforting
yeah i do you know if you have ended up
on
any like notable alumni lists yet have
you returned to lasalle academy in any
way
well you know i did a little interview i
want to say last year
so i did like an interview for the
alumni magazine yes
but um i haven't been back i would love
to go back i just haven't
it's so far away because i'm on the west
coast now it's interesting because um
some people that we've had on the
podcast have been rec
acknowledged by their high school and
others have like
looked at high schools
i know i have not yet been acknowledged
by high school but i'm hoping
someday soon yes um so this is the first
question that i like to ask because i
just feel like it sets the tone for
your whole high school experience so is
lasalle a public or private school
it's a catholic school yeah so private
catholic school
do you feel that teenage alissa lived up
to
the catholic school girl stereotype
yes and so does 30 year old alyssa those
catholic you go to a catholic school you
don't have another choice you it like
it deep you know it's the whole like the
parent being like i'm disappointed in
you that's
the whole education so you know you just
i
like catholic to me catholic yeah i very
much was a rule
follower and like i was raised greek
orthodox too so i would be going to like
church on sunday in greek orthodox
church and like greek school and then i
would go to
catholic school and go to math so i was
getting double duty
church wow
you're participating in a lot of rituals
so a lot of rituals a lot of singing
a lot of come to the feast of heaven and
earth
come to yeah i mean i i yeah and were
you
into it or were you like like dragging
your feet
going to church or what i probably was a
combo you know
i i just feel like church was kind of
like
camp as a kid like you know it was like
there were so many like
hot like you know who knows like
probably not hot now but you know when i
was a kid it was like oh my god
i have so many crushes at my greek
school and
i was in like you know greek dance so it
was all very like
there was a lot of community there that
excited me but i'm sure that
greek church is like three hours long so
i'm sure i was not eager to like
sit through church for sure it was more
like the social
aspect of like meeting other kids your
age
that would be around and stuff so greek
school
is that something that you do in the
morning no what i did if i remember was
it was like
after school so it was like uh like uh
learning greek but like an after-school
program type
okay yeah cause i've known like i think
i i've had like chinese friends who did
like a chinese school like there's
a lot of stuff like that but i was
always so impressed by people who did
stuff in the morning before
like before school can you even believe
we got up that early all the time as
kids
and then like six o'clock 5 55 a.m i
remember i
was up every day i know i that's so
crazy
now i can't get out of like now i
literally cannot
get out of bed until 9 00 a.m i'm in my
phone just like staring at me
i remember when i was in high school we
had like a large mormon population in my
school and i found out that the mormons
all met
up before school everyone was like you
know the mormons get together
in the morning and i was like that's
crazy
yes yes and but yeah even that it's like
clear
it's like oh yeah the mormons get
together now all of a sudden it's a cool
social thing so do
you have any like figures from your
catholic school like either
administrators teachers who sort of
still loom
large in your memory well i was a big
like
track runner like my life was track and
field
so i like very much my track coach will
always and forever be like
looming and be a big good figure in my
life
so beyond that i i definitely had some
teachers that i loved but i really
the main person i remember is my track
coach yeah and were you
performing at all then or was it just
all track
not really i really loved it in like
middle school i went to this like
arts sort of seventh and eighth grade
program no grades kind of just like
project based we did these things called
tension screams where we just go to the
field and scream
very cool oh my god yeah
do you still do do you ever like in your
regular life now you're like
i'm gonna go attention scream yeah you
know what i do and i it's not really
as possible in a city but like when i'm
really stressed i'll go for a sprint
i'll go i'll go because i was a sprinter
so i'll go somewhere
that it's not that populated and i'll
sprint and scream and there's no greater
feeling than sprinting it ah
it's very surprising but from an
outsider perspective
terrifying a woman sprinting
and screaming absolutely terrifying
yeah the location right yeah that is
true like if i
if i saw that i would be like oh my god
this is the beginning of a murder dog
it would be no questions asked it would
be no question and you would be running
through
you would you would go run too yeah yeah
i would be like okay someone is coming
actively like there's there's a danger
yes
um okay so you have listed you have it
seems a lot of different activities
going on so you've got track and field
you've got
greek school you've also got greek dance
and i also was a dancer so i was like
also dancing i want to say
five nights a week four nights a week so
that's my question is
what is your schedule
like at this point like how much time
did each thing take
up i think it's very telling like
because i think now i'm uh
i i think i was probably i just had too
much like
energy and and panic and i think it
really helped me to have a lot of
structure
because now i find myself like building
that structure into my life as an adult
and if i don't have that structure i'm
very like
i'm not good with an open day so i
remember i would go to school
i would go to track right after and then
i would go to a dance class from like
seven to eight at night and then i
i would like have dinner do homework and
then do it again
i was a prude i wasn't like okay i i was
very activity-based
couple pictures with your crew here now
let's get the squad in there
and this picture the the outfits the
fact that we all blindly followed each
other to the ends of the earth
with these white sports so i'm looking
at your crew and i'm saying when i see
these girls i'm saying this is a group
of good girls
yeah is that correct these are all my
track friends so we were all
like i feel like if you're a runner too
it's such a
it's such a not joyful sport there's no
jewel like it's such a masochistic sport
that if you're choosing that and
aggressively doing it as like a 13 14
year old
like you're a good per you're a good
girl you're a rule follower you know
because if not you're like
you're gonna cheer like why would i
there's no joy in
sprinting for two minutes this is that
like a running banquet
oh okay so you guys are and i can see
that you're dressed to the nines as you
can and we are drunk for the nines
definitely style icon was definitely
lizzie mcguire
hillary duff the bangs i remember going
and being like i need the side swept
bangs and coming out looking like a
full-grown dog and being like okay
this wasn't it but i whatever yeah well
that was such a thing too as a kid like
i just
never understood why my hair couldn't
look like the hair
of people on tv and i'm like girl
they're wearing a wig
oh my god it's so true it's a wig that's
why it looks like that
it's so true and also like don't you
just feel like we didn't
like the best thing you do when you grow
up is you learn your body and you learn
like what to wear for your
like i don't like follow trends now
because i'm like no if it doesn't work
for my body i'm not following the trend
but when you're young
you don't really know your body so
you're literally just following trends
no matter
what it does for your body so you're
just kind of blindly following like yeah
did you get into because i know like
you're focused on track you've got
you've got all of this religious
activity that's happening
yeah did you drink at all or
engage in any of that kind of stuff yeah
definitely like
by i want to say my senior year i like
tried it out a few times
for sure and like got in trouble a few
times and started experimenting so by
the time i went to
college like i definitely never smoked
pot and i definitely never like gotten
drunk but i had at least like tried
alcohol so it wasn't like but it just
yeah i i don't remember it being a huge
part of my life yeah i i was
like i again i like tried it starting
maybe like my
junior year and then i was just too
nervous about getting in trouble
to really fully give myself into it what
you said you got in a little bit of
trouble what was it
we a lot of us were at a party that got
like the cops called on it so
we all got like we i want to say like 30
people or something all got in trouble
because we were at a party and that was
what i was like oh well i'll never do
this you know ever again
it happened you know it was all like i
knew this i knew this was gonna happen
you know if and the thing was like yeah
drinking too is like you really
the only time that it's good to drink is
if you can really feel like you can let
loose and like you were never
you're doing something that was illegal
so you if you're someone who follows the
rules i just remember feeling uptight
all the time
i remember being so convinced that like
getting
into college was going to be this like
herculean task and like
most colleges would reject me and they
would rescind
my application at any time yes totally
i think they had to do that to us to
keep us engaged senior year
because they would they really hammered
that home of like but don't worry these
colleges they'll take it right away from
you
yes exactly i so i remember i was so
like i was so into the college
application process and i was such like
a
like i'm such a task person that i made
like a big list of all of my tasks do
you remember
that time in your life or did you like
know what school you wanted to go to or
were you just kind of like
all over the place like what was your
guiding i'm like usually really all over
the place with stuff and i'm usually bad
at decisions but i went on this trip
with my
with my dad we went and saw like i want
to say 10 colleges and i went to
middlebury and i was like this is where
i need to go and i just knew and we
stopped our trip after it and i applied
early decision
remember that where it was like
committing to the person remember that
yeah
yes and then i that was it
i remember like go everyone going around
school and talking about like
so-and-so applied early decision like
like it was like big news
who applied early decision
totally yeah so i remember that being a
very peace
peaceful decision i just like very much
knew i was very
yeah not to continue to go in on the
mormons at my high school but
i remember it was a big thing that they
would all
apply to like all of the ivs and get in
because they're up at four o'clock in
the morning
and they would tell everyone like they
would like let you know like okay we all
got into harvard but then they would all
go to byu
they would just apply so that we would
know
wow that's amazing
it was it was it was it was a power move
from the community
over the rest of us to let us know like
we could get in
to your fancy colleges we choose
we should go to utah
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast is
brought to you by
trivia star if i were to ask you to name
a member of the spice girls or new kids
on the block
could you do it in under 15 seconds yeah
yes you could well then you need to
download trivia star
trivia star is a free mobile quiz game
that is entertaining
yet challenging just like this podcast
you can choose from categories like
music sports movies tv animals
celebrities
there are over 60 categories to choose
from so there's always more
trivia to explore just think of how many
fun
facts you'll have to say at parties when
there are parties again
if you choose the correct answer from
multiple choice and beat the clock you
move on to the next level
the questions get harder over time but
never fear because you can use coins
and gems to get a hint to beat the next
level and trivia star has
two thousand five star reviews two
thousand
it's unbelievable in the apple store
join them today and see if you are smart
enough to win right now
trivia star is offering 2500 coins and
500 gems when you
download and play just go to the apple
or google store and
search trivia star again search trivia
star
for 2500 coins and 500 gems
download trivia star for free today
wow yeah what a crazy time like the k
the panic of everyone applying not being
sure what you got into
uh yeah do you remember
any like major scandals or like
big rumors from your high school
oh my god no i just i
oh god i mean all i have this vivid
memory of like going to
a prom when i was probably like a
freshman or sophomore so going like a
junior or senior prom when i was younger
and being very like still you know not
sure of
anything and i just remember someone
bringing
like a dozen roses in and then in all
the like little plastic
water on the bottom you know how they
have like plastic waters
they had they had vodka in all of them
they had alcohol and so i remember being
at the table and seeing them
take it off and put it in like their
diet coke and being like oh my god
this [ __ ] is real that's devious
yes yes that is and and did you partake
in that at all i didn't partake until it
was like all my friends in the basement
like are we doing this together like
yeah and like yeah mine is in a very
controlled setting
yeah you're crying you're like i guess
you're doing it i'm like spitting it out
i'm like oh
god yeah at my school i remember
so we usually just had like homecoming
and prom where like the two dances
but my soph my junior year
my class had a like like the junior
class so my like actual class
hosted a spring dance that they called
the crave
which stood for the cougar rave because
we were the oakton cougars
oh my god tell me you had to ask younger
students
um no that would have been amazing
in my head boogers senior girls asking
freshman boys
to dance but no that first of all if
anyone who
currently goes to oakton high school or
a cougar-based high school is like
listening to this nation bring back the
crave because the crave only
existed for one year because um a bunch
of people showed up on ecstasy
and then they never did it again uh but
what i always remember about it is
do you remember the oh my god shoes
video of course
one of the most the early youtube videos
yes
they did um they did an advertisement
for
the crave on the morning announcements
that was a parody of the oh my god shoes
video
where this very popular girl would go oh
my god
crave it's like not even it doesn't even
rhyme
that's classic it's just like no that's
not how a parody works you can just
insert a thing
no it was literally just this hot girl
going oh my god
crave everybody
there were no lyrics like there was the
parody was that thin
ah that is classic okay
so let's talk uh dating and boys and all
that stuff so you're going to
an older prom are you what
what's your dating situation like in
high school well i think we actually
have a picture i would love to pull up
for this
so my friend caitlin weirdly sent me
these last week and i was like this is
such
perfect timing the two of us became best
friends in like i want to say eighth
grade seventh and eighth grade and we
were
obsessed with these two guys to the
point of thinking we were like going to
marry
them i just remember never feeling so
obsessed with someone in my life so i
i my main memory of like
boys in high school in middle school was
blind obsession like i don't remember
why i liked them or what we even had in
common it was just
like pure hormonal like obsession
i didn't really think until like senior
year like until senior year i didn't
date someone who i was like oh this is
someone who i love
before that it was just like oh we need
each other's bodies
there's something so like innocent and
adolescent and fun about the unrequited
crush
oh it's so fun isn't it yes
it's like so painful at the time and i i
would feel it
so intensely your whole body it was like
the craziest
and yeah then you grow up and you like
have certain things you look for in
someone and things that like are big
turn-offs or big turn-ons
but when you're young like you don't you
you'll follow
anyone like you don't have your
personality quite yet so you're just
like
yes this person is my i will make them
my whole world
and you've never dated anyone so like
all of your understandings about love
and romance is
from television so you kind of turn the
person into your tv
boyfriend totally totally true yeah
and like yeah you're living in some your
parents house they're like your only
escape
too they're like yeah but i really
didn't fall in like i was so scared and
repressed i think
of like sex that i really was so scared
to fall in love because i was like then
i'm gonna have to like
have sex at some point that i feel like
i remember in high school just having
like
flirty things for a few until it got
serious and then i would be like no no
no
and then like you know senior year in
college that changed and i started
having real relationships
is that like in your flirting with were
these like
over aim or were they of course yeah
and i feel like that's got to be
happening we're both in relationships
but i feel like that's got to be
happening now
in the class like people are probably
getting like
like having fun like aim chats and
getting to know people on
whatever the equivalent is yeah yeah
it's interesting i'm like
aim should come back oh my god
for a time for aim yes i remember
i set an alert for my crush like i would
set a little thing to
tell me that he had come on and his
screen name was
dj school ditcher
can you get any more hot topic girl
crush than dj
school ditcher and he and i can still
see in my mind like
like his the thing of dj school district
coming up and it all had different
capitalization that's how we talked
that's how i remember the
remember how you had to talk like that
like hey hi what's up up and down what a
k
chaos yes and like i i would have to
wait
two seconds before messaging him so he
didn't realize that i had an alert
on for him i forgot about that i just
remember the sound of that door opening
like that is like the crack
like that hearing that door open and
then see your crush come on like your
whole body
trembled yes and i i don't know if you
felt the same way but i had so much more
confidence to talk to someone online
like i would
message a boy i'd never said [ __ ] to
whose
screen name i had heard him say on the
back
yeah it really was it's so true but then
but then i remember too like it didn't
change like
i would be so shy in school but then so
willing to talk on aim but then once you
get to school it's as if you've never
talked you're still
you're so uncomfortable it was like yeah
yeah
i would spend all night having like a
long conversation with a boy where we're
like
talking about all of our life and then
you see them at school and you don't
even
l you look away from you look away you
look away
it's embarrassing i know i know
oh god yeah
and and so when you finally started
having like real relationships is this
someone you're meeting in these other
activities
or remember the person who i like really
fell in love with i met at like a
like a greek festival like a church
occasion
and then i remember when i was like
falling in love with him being like
oh this is what it means it's that's the
crazy part of growing up too is like
oh i actually like this person i'm not
just like
i feel like so much of high school is
like oh my body's just like into this
person but then i'm like i don't know if
we really
i can't figure out why but i don't think
we really like each other and then once
you find someone you're like oh
i really like you as a person too that's
what first love is because you're like
your mind is blown that you're like my
body likes this person and
also like my mind and then you're like
oh forget it
i will yeah well done i'm cr this is
what creating a real connection with
someone else is like that's outside of
my mind just projecting
an oc character onto him
exactly making him be my seth cohen or
whatever um yeah yeah
so okay here's one other question i have
for you which is
what this is a general question what is
greek
dance what because you were saying like
what is that
i thought you'd never ask okay here we
go
okay uh so you get a it's a big i know
word backlit okay
so it's a nice hearty line dance so you
all kind of stand next to each other so
uh-oh all of a sudden okay we're
touching elbows we're touching shoulders
and there's a lot of just sort of it's
just all like lines so it's like
and it's just the same and it's like
very simple some are more
sound like some of the guys would do
crazy like yeah
like those were the guys that like you
really wanted to be with because they
were so
yeah in skirts like just very
but yeah so yeah that's really what it
was so you'd learn like
choreographed um dances together and
then you'd do them in a line
at like a greek festival and you know
it's like event of the summer
did you have crushes on boys from that
too because there's touching involved in
that
so yeah but the thing with that was like
there were like two guys that everyone
had a crush on
so it was kind of like there was there
wasn't even a chance i didn't even it
was like i'm not even gonna put my name
in the hat because
everyone likes these boys and i'm not
gonna
i but i used to have crushes on them
like but we all it was
back in the like collective crush day of
just all of us being like he's so dreamy
but no one really knowing who he was
yeah that is that is an interesting time
where it's just kind of like all the
girls decide together to have a crush on
one person
that's that's like such a thing that
does yeah like
it's sort of like how we treat
celebrities now that's how we treated
like
normal boys just like we all love
but ryan gosling is like nick and god
bless it if any of us
gets with him it probably won't happen
right
uh i remember when i went to camp there
was a hot
counselor which is like there's no
greater position of power than the hot
counselor wow none
and his everyone at camp had to have
like a special name
like the counselors you didn't call them
by their real names they had different
names and his name was wave runner
ugh so sexual
oh my god he knew what he was doing with
that nickname
he knew when he chose wave runner as
a 16 year old with bleached tips who
runs the mark like who runs water polo
and is in charge of 12 year old girls he
knew what he was doing
damn well what he was doing with that
nickname oh my god
and i remember like i went to camp i
didn't get to go to camp that's like one
of my i feel like camp must have just
been
like heaven for like being
yeah so i only went like i went in like
sixth grade
one time so i didn't really get to do
like
the full camp got it thing
um but i have friends who i feel like if
you're doing the
camp thing uh what i think of that is my
friends who went to camp every summer of
high school and had like another
life that had no bearing on their
current life
totally totally like like that's how it
felt and it was a whole different world
like i would go again i went to like
catholic camp so i remember going to
like a catholic camp with my church
group or like a christian camp i think
but it's like that one week two weeks
stints
that doesn't count it's when you went
all summer you saw the same people they
all had their cabins and their bunk
mates that's a different world that i
will
i would have loved to have been a part
of yeah and they'd come back like
knowing sex stuff that you were like why
yeah those people are the most advanced
they knew what hand jobs were when we
were
yeah we didn't even know what a penis
was yeah yeah it's
it seemed like a whole different
world to me like i i kind of idolized
camp in my mind but for some reason
even as a teenager i was like i'm just
not one of them i'm just not one of
the camp people i know because they
really had a life for quality about them
where
no matter what year it was they're like
i've been going to this camp for seven
years you're like oh
how did what we're only six exactly it
all no matter how young you were it
always felt like you were too late to go
together that's
so it yeah it's like you missed it we
already have secrets and we have inside
jokes and you wouldn't understand i was
also
so scared of sleepovers like i was so
anxious i could not sleep over even my
best friend's house i
i was like the last fall asleep i would
call my parents to pick me up i was a
mess that like
i think the idea of camp terrified me i
don't think i was strong enough
emotionally to
leave my parents i call my parents to
pick me up from the sleepover kid too
it's so funny when you look back being
like oh i was so anxious as a kid but
you didn't know what that meant
i was just it's so yeah now i'm looking
back like oh yeah you had severe anxiety
but you thought it was just like you
didn't like sleepovers it's like no you
like sleepovers but you're so
paranoid about not falling asleep that
you yeah
yes i remember what when i was in high
school i wanted to
switch from regular history
into honors history and i was
so fraught over the fact that i was
i thought i i had this weird assumption
that they weren't going to let me switch
and this was occupying such a huge place
in my brain that i remember i physically
couldn't eat
for two days because i didn't know and
it's like you build this whole world of
like what the history teacher's gonna
say and it's like none of it
that's why i'm telling you i am so
grateful for sports and and dance and i
really have to remind myself of that
even now of like when i'm when you're
spiraling or something you just gotta
like move your body and get like
like your brain is moving too fast and
your body's not and in quarantine
especially it's like
we gotta keep trying to to do things
because yeah the mind is a
yeah i'm sure you were able to switch
that class and it was fine oh
yes and i was so convinced that for like
the entire 24-hour period where i was
waiting to hear back that like
there was a dark meeting happening with
like my principal and every person i'd
ever met was like making a case for and
against why i should go to history and
it was literally just a matter of
someone like clicking a button
on a screen i know i know that's so
so relatable i mean we yeah it's so nice
having comedy and net now being able to
be like oh i know every i i now
feel uh yeah yeah and i mean it seems
like
you still have running in your life as
an
outlet to this day yeah i'm a little
injured my body's a little injured so
that's a bit tough
so i can't do it the same way i would
like to but
i i do it when i when i save it for like
when i need it i
i i use it yeah yes okay so i think
honestly this is a great place for us to
ask for me to ask you our final question
which is if you were to
speak to teen alyssa today what message
would you have for her
girl don't wear that skirt do not wear
that skirt do not pop that collar you
best believe that collar better be
unpopped take the earrings
out don't wax your eyebrows to
to nothingness and yeah be
surround yourself with people who who
make you
feel like your best self and you don't
have to do things you don't want to do
just i think that's a lesson i learned
every year of my life is just like
this is our life you don't have to do
anything you you don't want to do but
high school i think that's maximized the
most when you're a teen it's like just
thinking because everyone's like
doing this i have to do this thing but
it's like no if i could
go back i would just hang out with you
know
my friends who made me feel good and
yeah
yeah it's so funny to think back on like
it's been a really long
time since like i haven't had a friend
that i'm actually always
mad at like for such a long time that's
exactly it it's like that should not
right you don't need to have people who
make you feel bad you don't need to be
friends with people who you're
worried if they don't like you or not if
they you should never feel like
does my friend hate me that should not
that's not a friend
that's not but in high school for some
reason that was
always happening yeah i feel like in
high school you just always have one
friend who's actually openly cruel
towards you
it's so true why why are you
kind of have to you're all in the same
yeah you don't realize yet you don't
have to
yeah yeah like this person implies i'm
fat every day and i'm inviting them to
my birthday party because i
have to what's going on with that i know
i know i know uh okay well
listen it was amazing to talk to you
thank you
talking to you thank you so much for
coming on the pod i hope you're doing
well in quarantine and for everyone
at home listening this has been the
roast of your teenage self podcast
[Music]
bye
you